[Music]
[Music]
the world chess hall of fame
has been open in st louis for nine years
now but it did exist prior to its
opening
in september of 2011.
it moved here from miami florida and was
in washington dc
and in new york before that after the
museum in miami closed in 2008 it just
happened to be the exact same time that
the st
louis chess club opened in st louis in
the central west
end it made such a perfect fit to move
that museum here to st louis our mission
at the world chess hall of fame is to
educate visitors about
the rich cultural and educational
history
of the game of chess according to the
world chess federation
over 600 million people play chess
they're from all over the world they're
from all different groups and cultures
so whether you're a chess player or
you've never
played the game before you can come in
here
and really be inspired by by our
programming
in 2019 we had over 23 000 visitors
and that was the largest group of people
that we had entered into the building in
one year so we're really happy about
that
obviously because of covid19 we did have
to close temporarily
but we are open we're taking great
precautions to keep our staff
and our visitors safe and healthy and we
are starting to see our numbers go back
up and we've been really adapting
with kind of new ways of reaching our
audiences
through our programming and our music
series we're all wearing masks
we have hand sanitizer stations we do
health questionnaires and temperature
screenings before visitors come
in we also have a rich array of
educational programming available
throughout our website and on our
youtube page so if you can't come in and
see our exhibitions you can still learn
about them
on our website i would like to thank all
of our supporters
especially dr jeannie karen singfield
and rex singfield
for all they do for chess in st louis
and around the world
you